hi steve weintraub collider collider is
cool can you believe how amazing social
media has become that now
collider that can just be created by
people who just [ __ ] care about their
[ __ ] is actually taken [ __ ] seriously
um
yes and i i don't mean to to tangent
into this but um i i started it in my
bedroom um
you're the creator
yeah and so i'm just going to say thank
you for acknowledging the site and
that's very very cool of you um i want
to jump backwards when did you actually
feel like you had made it as an actor
where you could just act for a living
and not have to worry about paying rent
oh i'm always worrying about paying
around that's never going to go sorry um
i just have a lot of people you know
i've got three kids they're all school
it's a lot
um
i don't worry no but you're right okay
okay i hear you are here funnily enough
it was at the moment when i basically
quit which was just before westworld
and when i say i quit
i quit being an actor for hire
i want to do things that i would do for
nothing
because the thing that i should be being
paid for and i should be paying being
paid a lot is my human rights work which
i do
freely and with so much zeal and joy and
i do it for more time than i act
so for me it makes perfect sense it's
like oh actually
it's not me that's screwed it's the
world that's screwed i'm not being
compensated for the thing that's really
important but i am being compensated for
this other thing so i'll play along with
that and use that for that
and the moment that happened the fact
that it happened when i decided i didn't
want to do this [ __ ] show called rogue
because it was sexist and racist and
because they lied into me and cheated me
very badly um but it was okay because we
came to a
some kind of agreement but it was when i
decided that i was not an actor for hire
anymore is when i started doing
everything and it all just came to me
and people that weren't [ __ ]
i i completely understand what you're
saying and i am very happy for you thank
you
uh what is it like you've been friendly
with lisa for a long time now um
number of years what is it like for her
presenting you with a project is it
simple like text message or is it on the
set one day she's like i think i have
something for you you're great so this
is what happened and it was a little bit
of the second one but not quite we were
in singapore shooting the third season
of westworld it was great and we were in
the green room which is where we would
all gather before heading off to
different units to shoot and she was in
there on her computer and we all knew
that lisa was
having to
she was across westworld but was also
doing rewrites on her new movie that she
was going to shoot which were all so
excited for her
and i was i went over just to bother her
and say hi and she was like she looked
after her computer and said why can't
you play watts
and i didn't even know who watts was i
didn't know anything about her movie
other than it was meant to be amazing
and i've been on the hollywood blacklist
you know that thing the blacklist for
ages
i was like what do you mean she goes i
mean
why does she have to be like really like
you know big and and buff and why can't
she be like you i mean there's women in
the military like you
and i was like yeah i don't know anyway
love you gonna go two days later i'm
back in la and i get an offer for this
movie
lisa and i've got to tell you i really
wanted to say please don't lease i love
you so much what if this is the thing
that makes you wish you hadn't ever met
me you know what i mean like
please don't but then i got over my
you know self
my own
self-esteem issues
and we did it and it was amazing from
start to finish
to be part of the world that she created
the incredible
you know the the the technological
advancements that she had singing she
singularly
that was her
you know and hugh jackman is a dream to
work with and yes he's six foot what and
i'm
not six foot what and
but i believe it i believe like my
favorite scene in the movie not in the
movie my favorite scene of mine in the
movie is where i save his life and i
believe it i absolutely wholeheartedly
believe that this diminutive person
could do that and it was lisa stepping
out of a stereotypical it's like
she realized she'd internalize this view
of what women can and can't do
and similarly i had internalized this
view of what women can and can't do and
i desperately didn't want to sabotage
her movie
but
if you can't take risks
on your first movie when can you
honestly
so
i was the risk we took it and i just
hope with all my heart that it isn't a
death note
because i don't know but it was a
privilege
and i think she's amazing and i think
that this movie only if nothing else
shows that she should be making films as
often as possible and writing them every
single time can't wait for the next
season in westworld obviously have a
fantastic day and good luck with the
rest and thank you to you and all the
team at collider
every single one of them that make it
happen now that you're all rich and lazy
and just
swarming about [ __ ] your magazines on
the toilet while everyone does their
thing you know because you clearly
that's what you wanted to get across and
you did so all you other poor people at
collider who have to suffer this guy
congratulations everyone at collider
except you right they're gonna they're
gonna love that hey seriously thank you
so much um have a great day thank you
steve take care babe